[Music]
suicide squad was exciting to me because
we're going to introduce more dc
characters than any film has ever done
i forgot the rest
[Applause]
the suicide squad aren't really heroes
bloodsport
is quite a um
grumpy guy i'm not shaking the rat's
hand he's in prison for putting superman
in the icu
he just has barely enough humanity to
say uh all right i'll go fight where's
peacemaker says
nothing like a bloodbath to start the
day he's like a douchey bro but a
patriot at the same time he says
if it adds to peace you need to kill
people i got a clean shot on the only
one in the office
paulie is a catalyst of chaos i wanted
to see the harley quinn that i love from
the comics and the animated shows
kick ass in a way like she never had
before
with james it felt close to the source
material
i think king shark was my favorite
character it's just really stupid
but it's also really kind new friends
polka dot man is a product of uh
experiment
gone wrong redcatcher 2 controls and she
can talk with rats
stewie calm down with the rats she has
super strength super speed
she's just like a super [ __ ]
captain boomerang she's like the first
dude you wanna ever drink with but the
last one you want to be left at the bar
with
savant he's a distinctive looking chap
he's a very quiet very powerful guy
so this is the famous suicide squad love
him or hate him
oh so sorry these are your brothers and
sisters for the next few days
i leaned more into the kinder elements
of flag
blackguard the original character has
like
a really long purple ponytail there's
nothing cooler than being in the suicide
squad
yo is this a dog i'm gonna go with
afghan hound tdk is just
a guy whose arms and legs come off
that's his only power
formidable no annoying
[Music]
yes i love your accent
american women all love accents if you
imagine the most
sexy man or woman or
an animal a goose and then give this
person or animal
blonde hair and a very large toothpick
you would have javelin
characters considered throwaways or
worthless are very worthwhile and have
incredible meaning and value
i'm a superhero people will
stick with us and pray for us to survive
let me get you out of here i'm going to
get you out of here
what i didn't see coming was the
emotional depth
that is what the movie's about to me
[Applause]
the most brazen thing about the film is
the special moments between characters
it's just suicide well that's kind of
our thing
these are characters that anyone can
fall in love with and anyone can hate
i love the whole idea of the anti-heroes
i sort of like
playing the badass cruel decadent i've
been working all my life to blackness
i'm protecting this country they don't
know half of what i would do
there's so many great characters in dc
and being able to see different
expressions of those characters that's
so fun to me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you